la selva tropical más antigua del mundo
vuelve a manos de sus habitantes
ancestrales el gobierno del estado de
queensland en australia acordó devolver
más de 160 mil hectáreas de tierra al
pueblo indígena agulla la angie del este
que ha habitado este entorno por siglos
[Aplausos]
hoy es un evento muy importante para la
gente del google andy del este
no puedo explicarlo excepto que mi
corazón y mi espíritu están tan llenos
es alegre escucho la tierra escucho el
océano escucho los pájaros y me encanta
allí son los territorios serán
administrados conjuntamente entre los
nativos y el estado de queensland aunque
el objetivo es que con el tiempo pasen
completamente a manos indígenas
si hoy es un hito realmente importante
en la historia de queensland y realmente
corrige errores del pasado en ese estado
este es el hogar de la selva tropical
más antigua del mundo y esta revolución
realmente significará que la cultura
viva más antigua siga siendo capaz de
proteger esta importante actividad de
muchos proyectos también a ser conocida
por su belleza la selva de edad entre
alberga un rico ecosistema entre sus
huéspedes están el 30 por ciento de las
especies de marsupiales de australia y
el 20 por ciento de las de reptiles se
estima que comenzó a formarse hace 180
millones de años pero en los últimos
tiempos la industria de la la acorralado
ahora los pueblos locales buscan
protegerla con la creación de un refugio
natural y atraer visitantes que quieran
conocer los encantos de esta reliquia de
la naturaleza